ANTOINE BELLO:
Thank you, Olivier.
Thank you for giving me the tour
of the premises here in Paris.
I was very impressed,
but I guess
I don't have to tell you that.
I visited the Google campus
in Mountain View in California
and I have to say this one is
just as nice, if not nicer,
because it has this
Parisian cachet that they
don't have in California.
So kudos, guys.
It must be super
nice to work here.
Thank you for having me.
The truth might not exist, but
I know that you guys at Google
look very hard for
it so this should
make for an interesting
conversation.
Bear with me a moment.
I would like to take you
on a journey in the quest
for the elusive truth.
So we start our journey
in a small town courtroom
where a man is tried for
the murder of his wife.
According to the prosecutor,
he killed her in cold blood
at night in their home.
Everything seems to be
stacked against him.
He had money problems.
His rich wife threatened
to divorce him.
He had a mistress.
And jurors have been discussing
his fate for three days now,
and in a matter of
minutes they will
return to the courtroom
with the verdict
and they will tell
us, at last, what
happened on that fateful night.
And the journalists, of
course, are fretting.
At last we're going to
know the truth, they say.
The truth.
There could hardly be
a less accurate word
to describe what's about to
unravel, for the man will
initially be sentenced
to 30 years in jail
but will appeal the
judgment and receive
a much lesser sentence of five
years the second time around,
because the cold blood
murder will have turned
into an unfortunate accident.
The cold-hearted
killer will have
been demoted to a clumsy
and temperamental husband,
and in a matter
of months, justice
will have spoken two
different truths.
As hard as it is to admit,
we'll never know for sure
what happened on that night.
Who should we believe?
Should we believe
the husband who
swears that he pulled
the trigger by mistake
and claimed that his
wife used to make
him beg for pocket money?
Or should we believe
the prosecutor
who invokes premeditation
and portrays the victim
as a humiliated woman?
Even facts don't
help us that much.
The man's fingerprints were
found on the rifle's trigger,
but it doesn't prove anything.
It doesn't prove that he
pulled it in cold blood.
He could have stumbled.
Maybe he was
provoked by his wife.
We'll never know.
Even the accused doesn't
know anymore, for reasons
that we will discuss later.
OK.
So at this point, we have
established that journalists
have a tendency to speak
a little bit too casually
about the truth, but
this is hardly a scoop.
Journalists are not alone.
We all have a strange
rapport with the truth.
Simply put, we tend to confuse
the truth with reality.
Reality is what is.
It is unique and
can be expressed
in purely factual manner.
The shot was heard at 10:43 PM.
The shooter was within
six feet of the victim.
$1,000 were withdrawn
from the joint account
on the day of the murder.
That's reality.
But truth?
Truth doesn't exist,
or rather, there
are an infinity of truths
depending on who you ask.
If you believe the
prosecutor, the man
calmly took aim at his wife
and put a bullet in her gut.
But if you ask the
defense attorney,
his client was nervously
clenching the trigger
and the gun
accidentally went off.
Those affirmations posing
as truth are nothing
more than interpretations, the
expressions of subjectivity,
or, to be more
provocative, just fictions.
For 15 years, I've been
trying in my novels
to explore the reasons why
we confuse fiction and truth.
I will share with you some of my
findings, and as you will see,
they have a lot to do with
the way our brain works.
Let's start at the beginning.
What separates man from animal?
Some people will tell
you that conscience does,
others that it's language.
For me, the answer is stories.
The Homo sapiens has always
produced and consumed
an astounding
quantity of stories,
from the inhabitants
of the caves of Lascaux
to the clients of Netflix
who binge on TV series.
But luck has no
place in evolution.
If the frequency of a hereditary
feature increases over time,
it is because it
improves the survival
prospects of the species.
Modern man being the result of
millions of years of evolution,
if we keep telling stories, we
must derive benefits from it.
Which benefits?
I see two main ones.
First, unlike animals,
we have the ability
to believe in inter-subjective
realities, such as nations,
church, or money.
As Yuval Harari
explains in his book,
"Sapiens," you will never
take a banana from a monkey
by telling him he will
get 100 in the afterlife.
We humans buy into
those stories.
They enable us to create
larger and more complex
societies than animals.
Once you've reached the
threshold of a few hundred
individuals, you
need glue to maintain
the cohesion of the group.
Stories are that glue.
The second advantage of stories
is of greater concern to us.
To use a simple analogy,
stories are a life simulator,
comparable in
principle to the flight
simulators on
which pilots train.
The anecdotes that
pepper our conversations,
the books we read,
the movies we watch,
prepare us to the situations
we will encounter,
sparing us costly
mistakes and giving us
the opportunity to live
hundreds of lives at once.
Before a teenager says, "I
love you" for the first time,
he or she has experienced
hundreds of love stories
by proxy.
The soldier about
to be deployed knows
what to expect thanks to "Saving
Private Ryan" and "Full Metal
Jacket."
And all husbands know the
risk of an extramarital affair
after they have seen
"Fatal Attraction."
Because we consume
so many stories,
our brain has gotten used to
connecting facts in that form.
The following example comes from
my novel, "The Showrunners."
Let's say you get on to a
train and walk to your seat.
The ticket inspector
stands next to a passenger,
a young backpacker with a
three-day stubbled beard.
The young man is
searching his pockets.
You don't really pay
attention to the scene
until the next day when
a friend of yours talks
about the cost of fraud
in public transportation.
You then share with him
the episode you witnessed.
I intentionally use
the word episode,
for your brain will have
organized this handful of facts
in a cohesive story with
a beginning, a middle,
and an end.
It will play
something like this.
The train inspector asked
to see everybody's tickets.
The backpacker didn't have one.
The inspector wrote
him up a ticket.
The backpacker dug in
his pockets for money.
Now please consider the
number of implicit assumptions
in this scenario.
A man with a blue
shirt and a cap
is automatically
a train inspector.
A backpacker is a natural
candidate for fraud,
and anybody with their
hands in their pockets
has to be searching for money.
I'm sure you realize
that this scene offers
several other explanations.
Maybe the train inspector
had finished the service.
He was headed to the restaurant.
His son, who was
traveling with him,
was giving him money
to buy a sandwich.
Or the inspector
wrote up a ticket
to an old lady who gave
him a 100 Euro banknote,
and the inspector
asked other passengers
to help him with the change.
Those would be
possible scenarios.
Of course your scenario,
the initial scenario,
is by far the most likely.
But that's exactly my point.
From the moment that
a likely scenario
takes shape in your brain,
it becomes a certainty.
You're convinced you
witnessed a train inspection.
Scratch that.
You witnessed a
train inspection.
The story has become a fact.
Fiction has become reality.
Just to be sure, you will
have retained no other memory
from this train ride.
You walked up the aisle.
A backpacker had no ticket.
That's all you'll
remember in a week or two.
At the time, though, you had
noticed a few other details--
a scarred man in
uniform, newspapers
cramming into the trash can.
Those details vanished
almost immediately,
dispelled by other equally
insignificant details.
You forgot them because they
weren't part of a story.
Which leads us to another
function of stories.
They are mnemonic devices.
Because it's easier to remember
the sequence 1, 2, 3, 4,
5 than 5, 3, 2, 1, 4,
our brain provides us
with the illusion of an order by
positing a chronology or causal
links that do not exist.
That's how a woman walking down
the street at 8:00 AM holding
the hand of a young
girl with a backpack
automatically becomes a mother
taking her daughter to school.
If you have taken
one of those tests
where you have to commit to
memory as many random objects
as possible in a
limited time, you
know the secret is to weave the
objects into a little story.
That's exactly the same point.
Recent discoveries
in cognitive sciences
have shown that we
have two selves.
The first one feels.
The second one
narrates and gives
meaning to what we experience.
The first one feels a stinging
pain in your index finger.
The second one
says, oh, you just
burned yourself by taking
a dish out of the oven.
Our memories are stories too.
We tend to think
that our brain stores
memories like YouTube videos
you can replay on demand.
That would be nice.
Big market for you.
Nothing could be
further from the truth.
Sounds, pictures,
smells, emotions
are stored in different
areas of your brain.
When you're about
to tell an anecdote,
you summon all these
memories and hastily craft
a speech based on who you
talk to and how long you have.
The first times you
tell the anecdote,
your story is still fluid.
You experiment with words.
You try variations.
Over time, however, your
story tends to solidify.
You use the same adjectives
over and over again.
You make the jokes that you
know will get you the laughs.
The final version
usually has little
to do with the
original one, which
doesn't prevent you from being
100% sincere when telling it.
In "The Showrunners,"
again, a character
called Vargas asks the
hero, Sliv, to share
with him a personal memory.
Sliv, who lost his father to
a brain tumor when he was 10,
chooses to recount the last few
weeks of the [? diseased. ?]
How his dad repainted
the yard fence because he
wanted to leave a
clean house behind him.
How every morning he would
recite the first verses
of the saga of Erik
the Red when shaving
to check that his
memory was still intact.
How he died on the
gloomiest of days
with all the lights in the
house turned on despite the fact
that it was noon.
"What a beautiful
story," commends Vargas.
"Too bad it isn't true."
And Sliv takes offense,
as you probably would,
of Vargas's insinuations.
It's the most painful
episode of his life.
Why would he make any
of those details up?
But Vargas seems pretty adamant.
He insists that Sliv compare
his memories with those
of other members of his family.
So Sliv flies to Iceland
to confront his mother,
and much to his
surprise, he discovers
that Vargas was right.
Sure, Sliv's father
repainted the fence,
but he did it two years prior
to being diagnosed with cancer.
He didn't recite the Saga of
Erik the Red in the morning.
He didn't know one
verse of poetry.
And Sliv's mother remembers
that the sun was shining when
she closed her husband's eyes.
"How can one die on
such a beautiful day?"
she remembers
thinking at the time.
Sliv and his mother have
lived through the same scene,
but they've each come away
with a different interpretation
of that day.
Once again, one
reality has given birth
to two different truths.
So memories are stories.
History, with a capital
H, is a story too.
Take the example of jazz.
Encyclopedias will
tell us that jazz
is in African-American
music, a mix of gospel,
blues, and of the songs
that the slaves used
to hum in the plantations.
Some sources also mention the
role played by the Jim Crow
laws in the 1890s that increased
segregation in the South
and led African-American
musicians to regroup
in small bands.
At this stage of
my presentation,
though, I hope you
realize that all this is
pure speculation,
a ludicrous attempt
to connect independent facts.
Just as we established the
difference between reality
and truth, we need to understand
the difference between the past
and history.
The past is what
really happened.
It is a fact that
African-American slaves
used to sing gospel at the
end of the 19th century.
It is a fact, too, that
the parliament of Louisiana
passed a particular law in 1892.
Yet making those
events milestones
in the birth of a movement, one
we'll arbitrarily call jazz,
is telling a story,
like gathering
beads of various colors and
sizes to make a bracelet.
The truth does not exist.
It is constantly
being recreated.
You know the saying, history
is written by the victors?
This is so accurate.
Imagine what our children
would be learning in school
if Hitler had won World War II.
It would read something
like, "The biggest benefits
of the war is to have
rid us of the Jews,
a harmful and
despicable race which
used to control all the levers
in international finance."
No comment.
If you start paying
attention, you
will notice that stories
are everywhere-- in manuals,
in our memories, in
religion, in current events,
and even in science.
This might come as
a surprise to you.
In science?
But of course.
For centuries the
Earth was flat.
Then it became round.
Then it started to
revolve around the sun.
Every time the followers
of the old theory
called the new theory a hoax,
and every time the disruptors
thought they had revealed
the laws of the universe
and believed they would
never be supplanted.
Copernicus was right to
claim that the Earth revolves
around the sun, but
he wrongly assumed
that the Earth followed
a circular trajectory,
while in fact it's elliptical.
Copernicus's mistake
was pointed out
and rectified by
Galileo and Newton, who
then made other mistakes.
It's the nature of the
scientific process.
Some of the theories our
children learn in biology class
today would have been
deemed heretic 30 years ago.
Which leads me to an
obvious observation.
Theories are stories too.
Let's take the example of the
Big Bang, the massive explosion
that gave rise to the universe
some 14 billion years ago.
As I speak, there are about 100
theories about the Big Bang.
Most of them come from
phonies, but 10 or 12
emanate from highly
distinguished astrophysicists.
Since only one of these
theories, at most,
can be correct, it means that
all the others are stories.
I can't think of a better
word to describe them.
Stories.
Stories crafted in good faith,
but stories nonetheless.
Besides, and I will push the
envelope a little bit here.
Besides, even if one of these
theories turned out to be true,
I would personally still
consider it a fable.
If there are
scientists in the room,
and I bet there are today,
they must think I'm crazy.
Newton's Law of Universal
Gravitation is not a fable.
Yet I persist.
Granted, objects are attracted
toward the center of the Earth,
but when Newton attributes
this phenomenon to a force
equals gravity, I
personally attribute it
to the god, Gravitor,
who punishes
men for Icarus's arrogance
by pinning him to the ground.
Moreover, I'm sure you
know that Newton's theory,
though it accurately predicts
the movement of asteroids,
it's useless to
predict the movement
of very small particles,
which means it is wrong.
I'm not worried.
Someone will improve on it.
Every story displaces
the previous one.
There was a time when the
universe was 6,000 years old.
Then it was 100 million
years, then a billion.
We currently stand at 14.
Why should we stop there?
So now you might wonder--
I wonder that
question all the time,
especially since my job is
to craft good stories when
I write books--
what makes a story powerful?
The stories we're
talking about, they
conform to the
laws of Darwinism.
Only the best stories survive.
One day, one year, centuries
for the most robust ones.
As a rule of thumb, art
is stronger than reality,
myth are more
resistant than fables,
and religions have a thicker
skin than political ideals.
But why is it that some stories
withstand this test of time
while others are soon forgotten?
In other words, what
makes a story powerful?
It is a subtle alchemy,
the miraculous combination
of eternal ingredients--
mankind's biggest
myth, of course,
but also local cultures and
the spirit of the times.
Take, for instance,
the movie "Titanic"
and see how many timely
themes it calls upon--
the hubris of man, true love,
impossible love, class warfare,
and so many others.
Every country has their
own prism through which
they see the world.
Americans, for
instance, can't get
enough of superhero stories.
Think Batman, Spiderman,
X-Men, and you can name
probably many, many others.
This taste for superheroes
has several roots--
the protestant belief
in predestination,
the myth of America
as the promised land,
and, last but not least,
a die-hard [INAUDIBLE]..
For many Americans, the
world is fundamentally
the place where the good
and evil battle it out.
As George W. Bush put it when
he was trying to recruit allies
before invading Iraq, "You're
either with us or against us."
We, the French, have a
fondness for have-nots and
underprivileged characters.
Mexicans are suckers for
a good revenge story.
The Japanese can't resist
a tale of heroic sacrifice.
Once in a while, a story
arises that transcends
ethnical and religious
divides and reminds us
that we belong to
a greater whole,
a bit like the
brother and sister who
bury the hatchet the day when
they step into a new school.
Space travel, or first contacts
with alien civilizations,
are among the truly
universal themes.
So what we called the
truth does not exist.
Most of the time, it's only a
shortcut, an interpretation,
a story something
is trying to sell us
or one we're trying
to sell to ourselves.
You might wonder whether
being aware of it
has changed my behavior.
It has.
First, I don't fall as
blindly for my own tales.
Every time it's possible,
I go back to the facts.
I don't ignore my
emotions, but I
try to understand
where they come from.
In a way, I try to separate the
feeling me from the narrating
me.
Very important to know which
one is talking at the moment.
Second, I can tell when
the person speaking to me
is making up their own truth,
and surprisingly, this often
triggers a rush of
empathy towards them.
Third, I'm wary of the
simplistic messages
of political leaders, large
corporations, intellectuals,
and generally speaking,
all the people who
claim they hold the truth or
even a fragment of the truth.
And last, I support
all attempts to rise
above the very notion of truth.
From that perspective,
no project
is more admirable to
me than Wikipedia.
I'm sure you know and use
it as an encyclopedia,
but Wikipedia is
much more than that.
It is, in my eyes, a tool
to get closer to the truth.
As you well know, any user can
create and modify an article
without any
credentials and without
any technical knowledge.
Some articles get modified
dozens of times in a day.
Let's take, for instance,
the page of George W. Bush.
Bush is, to use a euphemism,
a controversial figure,
a hero to some and a
numbskull to others.
Yet his Wikipedia page
is remarkably balanced.
Why is that?
Because by nature Wikipedia
doesn't tolerate extremism.
Try to write, "Bush is a
moron," and your contribution
will be overturned immediately.
But write that "One of
the reasons Bush ignored
the intelligence reports
of his own administration
is that he was surrounded by
neoconservative advisors who
wanted to restore American
military supremacy
in the Middle East," and you
will last a little bit longer,
because somewhere in Texas,
a die-hard Republican will
be going over your
lines, looking
in vain for a good
reason to reject them.
From the confrontation
of your two brains,
a new formulation will arise.
It will not be the
truth, since remember,
the truth does not exist.
But it would be a
start, a first step
toward the construction
of a representation
acceptable by all or nearly all.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Maybe I can
ask the first one.
ANTOINE BELLO: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hopefully
I'll inspire others.
So with that premise,
how do you live your day?
It seems like everything
you're saying makes sense,
and yet we must carry on.
You probably have
your own beliefs.
How do you make sense of
your intellectual stance
on the issue of truth,
but then decisions
you make about what you
do with your day, what
you make of current events?
ANTOINE BELLO: I'm extremely
skeptical of current events.
I read several newspapers.
The founding experience for
me was when I moved to the US
in 2002.
It was at the time when
Bush was building up
his coalition to invade Iraq.
And in France, when I
used to live in France,
I would read "Le
Figaro" and "Le Monde"
and I thought I was
pretty well-informed.
And I arrived in
the US and I started
to read the "New York Times"
and the "Wall Street Journal"
and, oh my god, this is a
completely different story.
This story has just nothing
to do with the French one.
And that, I think, for me it
was a formative experience
because I started to realize
that it's all our perception.
It has to do with our
country, with our religion,
with our culture, with, you
know, they are Protestant,
we are Catholic.
They practice religion.
We don't.
They have a certain
vision of the Middle East.
We have a totally different
one, for historical reasons.
And instead of being--
you can get stuck
there and say, OK,
there is no reason
to do anything,
because I could read the
papers from the other country
and that would completely
negate my reasoning.
But I think it's the opposite.
You try to go on with your
day knowing that everything
around you is competing
stories, stories competing
for your attention, stories
competing for your addition,
and you don't have to
be a prisoner to that.
You can see that, with
a bit of perspective,
a bit of a grain of
salt, and I think
that makes you a happier man,
a freer man, that's for sure.
It might be a little bit
challenging sometimes.
You said, you must have
beliefs like anybody.
Of course I have beliefs.
I think the key is to know
when your beliefs are beliefs
or when your beliefs are
certainties or truth.
It's not the same thing.
I don't mind having beliefs as
long as I can keep telling they
are beliefs and not
everybody shares them.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thanks for the talk.
Are you not concerned that by
preaching about there not being
any truth, that
everything is stories,
you could be discouraging
people from learning?
And for a pragmatic
example, let's
take an example from nutrition.
There will be people
who will be saying,
oh, for every paper that says
that coffee's good for you,
there's another that says that
it's bad for you, so I give up.
I will not educate myself
because there is no consensus
to be found.
Even if there is a
consensus and they
could have healthier
lives, [INAUDIBLE] there
is some truth to be learned.
ANTOINE BELLO: That's
a very good question.
I have four kids, and
when they were babies,
there was the question
of should we lay them
down lying down on the back
or lying down on the belly.
And this is funny,
because you read
a book that was written 20
years ago, it was one way,
and now it's the opposite.
And oh my god, you could
be endangering your kids
if you lie down on the belly.
But that's what our
parents have done.
Oh yes, but they were
taking such risks.
They didn't know it
at the time, but--
and what's funny is that
10 years down the road,
it's going to be the opposite.
In some instances, on
some particular facts,
there seems to be so
much flip flopping
that I can't fathom how people
can still be serious about it.
I think if I was a pediatrician
I would tell my patients,
yes, right now we say that
you should lay them down
on the back, but honestly
we don't have a clue.
This could change.
So if you have to
choose, choose the back.
Maybe a 60% chance.
I would be honest about it.
But I think I would
lose a ton of patients.
It's not the right way to do.
Our system, in a way, is
geared toward more conviction,
more beliefs, people affirming
their beliefs even more.
And I would say
probably the less sure
they are about their beliefs,
the more they affirm them.
And that's something that, to
me, that's extremely worrisome.
So what I tell my kids today,
for instance, about nutrition
or about other
subjects, is study.
Get your facts together.
Try to develop an opinion.
Confront your
opinion with others.
Remember it's an opinion.
Remember it's a way
of articulating facts.
It's the image that I
used earlier in the talk
when I said it's about picking
beads from various sizes
and colors to make
up a bracelet.
You have different points.
You think you have the one
path that unites them all
and you're saying that
this is the truth.
Well, guess what.
There are many ways
to unite all those.
You could be doing like this.
It would be a completely
different idea,
but it wouldn't be less
structured an opinion.
So no, it's still possible
to live with this belief
that stories are everywhere.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
So I had an anecdote to start.
Back in, I think, 2005, I was
living in Asia at the time,
and I went to the island
of Sumatra in Indonesia.
And at that time that island
suffered, over two years,
I think, both a
massive earthquake
and a tsunami, two
natural disasters
of quite big proportions.
And the local newspaper
reported a story
that a certain
party of I would say
fundamentalist Islamic
people were explaining
to the population
that the reason why
these disasters happened
was because they had been
bad Muslims and they
hadn't really followed
the rules of their religion.
And to my absolute
huge surprise,
I heard that this political
party was actually
gaining a lot of traction, were
actually showing up as likely
to win the next elections.
So my question to
you would be this.
This is obviously a
story and not the one
that I would have
invented for myself.
Though I think that there had
been two disasters in a row,
I would not have
attributed that to a god.
But do you think
that some stories
have a higher value than other,
or are better than others?
ANTOINE BELLO: Of course.
AUDIENCE: Do you think it's
possible to create a hierarchy?
ANTOINE BELLO: Of course.
Of course.
If it were not, I guess I
wouldn't be doing this job.
I wouldn't have been
an entrepreneur before.
I would be a prophet or
I would be evangelizing
these very credulous people.
Of course there is a hierarchy.
I have the utmost respect
for the scientific process,
for the scientific profession.
We need people to keep working
on the edge of the universe.
on the trajectory of asteroids.
We need that.
They give us
invaluable information,
and that information, once we
have it, we cannot forget it.
We cannot pretend
that it doesn't exist.
So everything we know about
climatology, for instance,
tells us that there is a very,
very, very low probability
that those two catastrophes
that you mention
were caused by the behavior of
some Muslim people somewhere
in Sumatra.
So I attach a very,
very, very low proportion
to that probability.
Yet what I think is crucial is
to know that some people pin
a pretty high probability
to that scenario,
and we live with those people.
We share the same world.
And it can be a bit
scary sometimes,
but it's not something that
you can afford to forget.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
[INAUDIBLE] I think we moved
to the US at the same time.
ANTOINE BELLO: Really?
AUDIENCE: The war, [INAUDIBLE],,
to have a French accent
was a horrible time, to have
a French accent in New York
or Miami.
You were saying that--
my question is,
what worries you?
Because [INAUDIBLE] and I agree
with you, but what worries you?
Because we are in this society
that we have all more access
to information, so we can
check different stories
and bring our own truth.
But also, everybody
has an opinion,
so even anybody can do a YouTube
video and explain dumb stuff
and have a follow-up.
So my question is,
what worries you
and what do you think
will be a solution on top
of better education, et cetera?
Could you say it worries you
that we live in this world
right now?
ANTOINE BELLO: From
the top of my head,
intolerance is the one thing
that worries me the most.
It's the reason why I commit
so much for Wikipedia.
I've been a strong supporter
of Wikipedia for years now.
I think they do an excellent
job and a very important job
at disseminating information,
and disseminating information
that has managed to
build a consensus.
And that, to me, is
absolutely crucial.
And it's not a coincidence if
Wikipedia is banned in China,
is banned in Turkey, was
sometimes banned in France.
Would you believe it?
Certain articles were
blocked in France,
which is no longer possible.
Wikipedia has changed
the way they operate.
Now you have to ban
the entire site.
You cannot ban only a
selected few articles.
So intolerance
obviously scares me.
And intolerance, I think--
what scares me is
people, what they
call the useful idiots or the
people who think they know,
they think they are
in control, and they
should be the one admitting that
they know very, very little.
Citizens who don't inform
themselves, for instance,
who don't do their job.
I think citizen is a job.
Citizen is not a right.
Well, it is obviously
a right, but it
comes with duties
and responsibilities.
Going to vote without
doing your homework, to me,
is a betrayal of
the democratic pact,
and it is a betrayal
that many, many people
are guilty of today.
So that worries me.
AUDIENCE: First of all, I never
realized that storytelling
was so pervasive.
Maybe a lot of you
are similar to me,
but I have a longtime
friend that we've
known for several years and
who consistently tells stories.
We've stuck with him
throughout-- a lot
of people, when they meet
him, they kind of find
it kind of comical.
We call it giving
him an 80% discount,
because we know that
probably his story started
with a fact somewhere, but then
he added 80% to 90% of a story
on top of it.
My question is, because
we have discussions
amongst friends about, should
we try to intervene and get him
some help?
Because it affects
his personal life.
Most people are not attracted
to a person where they obviously
are telling stories that are
obvious stories all the time.
Or should we just leave
it, because his ego
is now all caught up.
He believes his own
stories, of course,
so his ego is all
caught up in the stories
that he's fabricated on this
fictional life, essentially.
So it's a complex issue.
I just wanted to
see if you had--
ANTOINE BELLO: How old is he?
AUDIENCE: He's in his mid 40s.
ANTOINE BELLO: My last book,
the one that some of you
have in front of them,
[SPEAKING FRENCH],,
is about a pathological
impostor and his relationship
with his psychiatrist, and
the way this relationship
develops over the years,
over the decades, even.
I've documented myself
quite a bit for that book.
I've read a lot about
pathological liars
and imposters.
My experience-- the take
away from my reading
is that you won't change him.
He's too old.
If someone maybe had attracted
his attention earlier
and had showed him exactly
where he had derailed
and the impact and the damage
it could do to his entourage,
maybe you would have been able
to put him back on tracks.
But I don't really believe that.
Even in his 20s it would have
been difficult. In his 40s
he's probably a lost cause.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I kind of share that
opinion as well.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: There's a
question over here,
but it could come
back to me after.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Thanks [INAUDIBLE].
So it was just about democracy,
because [INAUDIBLE] before.
So democracy writes
their own stories,
and they are very [INAUDIBLE]
against the stories
by extremism.
And I just want to know
what you think about that.
ANTOINE BELLO: I'm sorry.
What I think about what?
AUDIENCE: About this,
I think democracies
have [? a hard ?] time to
write compelling stories.
ANTOINE BELLO: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Compared to the
stories made by the extremism.
ANTOINE BELLO: OK.
I get the question.
I'm not really sure about that.
Probably the best
story about democracy
is the American story.
They did a pretty good job.
They did a very, very good job.
The house up on the hill
and the promised land
and the Constitution,
the Founding Fathers,
all that wisdom pouring into
the country; a text that
has withstood the test of
time; the justices that
can tell the law once
in a while when need be;
the president, the
checks and balances--
it's a very, very good story.
I live there and I base
in that story every day,
and I have to say, as a
storyteller, everyday I think,
they're pretty good.
They're pretty good.
Yes, the fascist
regimes, for instance,
have different stories and
can have compelling stories
if you are in the right camp.
If you're not one of
the Jews or homosexuals,
I guess you might
like that story.
Some people don't.
But those stories, honestly,
I'm not sure they're that good.
I mean, when you think about
the national socialism,
it lasted for only
10 years, 12 years.
Communism is almost--
well, I won't
say forgotten, but
except for Venezuela
and I won't say
China, but it has
disappeared from almost
everywhere in the world.
It's what I was trying to say.
Religions usually last much
longer than political ideals.
Political ideas pass much
more quickly than we think.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
sharing your story about truth
and its non-existence.
I also admire Wikipedia
a lot, and you
said it's a place
that helps people
as they move to better
stories, you might say,
or stories that are more useful.
So Wikipedia is
built on a governance
which is really effective.
People can bring ideas.
They can bring
credibility and expertise
and there's a whole
bunch of mechanisms
that help that process.
That sort of
governance seems to be
important to allow stories to
get better and to be explored.
Where are some other
places in which governance
exists that you admire and
respect of that nature,
whether it's in the pursuit
of better stories or better
institutions?
ANTOINE BELLO: First, a
side note on Wikipedia.
The governance is much
lighter than you think.
For instance, the credibility
of the person who writes
is never taken into
account, and you
would think, oh my god,
that's how you end up
having so poor pages.
But that's quite the opposite.
People who don't feel empowered
to write about the subject
simply don't.
And I can tell you
on the other end,
I've tried to rectify
something on my Wikipedia page.
I was banned from it.
You would think
that you know best.
No, you don't.
Because maybe, Mr. Bello, you
have a problem with the truth.
Maybe your memories
were a story as well.
So I'm not sure I really
see that type of governance
anywhere else or I
admire it anywhere else.
What I see is that large
companies like yours
are trying, at the moment, to
get to something like that.
Facebook is trying very hard
with their tens of thousands
of fact checkers.
And Google, you have a
lot of processes in place,
the right to be forgotten
and you can report bad pages
or you can report every time you
suspect a scam or an operation
to increase the search
engine ranking of a page.
You can alert Google to it.
I think that's pretty powerful.
It's only the beginning, though.
And your company, probably,
among all the others,
probably has the
biggest responsibility.
If I remind correctly,
the goal of Google
was to organize all the
information around the world.
Wow.
That's a tall order.
You'd better get it
right for our sake.
AUDIENCE: It's not just that.
It's also to make it universally
useful and accessible,
and that question of universally
useful and accessible
is obviously a question which
involves multiple perspectives.
ANTOINE BELLO: Yes,
exactly, and I'm not--
for instance, there is
this debate right now
about should Google go back
to China, for instance,
and tailor the search
engine to the needs
of the Chinese government.
I follow this debate and
I find it fascinating,
to be honest, because I don't
have the answer to that.
There is a part of me who
says, no, of course no.
Don't go to China.
They banned Wikipedia.
Why would Google go and get in
bed with the Chinese leaders?
And at the same time
I have to think,
a search engine that would
do 99% of what Google does
in the rest of
the world would be
a nice service to
the Chinese people
and would accommodate,
like you said,
their vision of the world
which is not the same as ours,
and ours is not better.
So it's typically the type of
subjects where I am divided
and I refrain from
the temptation
of judging too quickly.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Two more
questions, please.
ANTOINE BELLO: Over there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
I'm curious in the idea
of bringing this consensus
to the political area
to explain my point
and to ask your opinion.
Some democracies that try
democracy by consensus,
it brought some
weaknesses to them
because it takes time and
effort and it's easier
to be quick and not
make the efforts.
Do you have an opinion
on that or do you--
ANTOINE BELLO: Not really.
It would be a stretch to say
that I have an opinion on that.
I lived in Japan for a while.
I lived in Japan for a
year and a half in the '90s
and I was extremely impressed
by their governing by consensus.
It was extremely
impressive, the way
they were able to raise the
age of retirement at the time
without any dissent, without
anybody taking to the streets.
It was a lesson to me
in reason and democracy.
At the same time,
I know it comes
with plenty of inconvenience.
Like you said, the democratic
process in Japan is slow.
Political parties
and politicians
are corrupted and can be easily
bought, from what I hear.
So I won't make it an example.
But no, I don't have a
firm opinion on that.
AUDIENCE: Last question.
AUDIENCE: One last question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for the talk.
I was curious what's your view
on artificial intelligence
and the evolution of
that technology based
on the fact that more and more
we'll be using data provided
by, or information provided by
machines, as the truth somehow.
ANTOINE BELLO: I'm so interested
by artificial intelligence
that I wrote a whole
novel about it.
It's called "Ada,"
A-D-A. It's the name
of an artificial intelligence
developed in the Silicon
Valley, not far
from Mountain View.
In Mountain View,
actually, I think.
No, in Stanford.
And that gets stolen.
And the program gets stolen,
disappears from the hard drive,
and the question is, now we have
this program out in the open,
what will anyone do with it?
What will it do with itself?
My role as a writer is
not to provide answers.
I think it's to ask the
questions in an elegant manner.
So I think that's what I
tried to do in "Ada," explore
all the possibilities offered
by artificial intelligence.
And there are
many, but of course
reminding the reader of all
the risks that go with it.
And there is no real conclusion
at the end of the book.
I think any
conclusion would have
been a usurpation of my powers
and privileges as a writer.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, everyone.
So I think it's the end.
ANTOINE BELLO: OK.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
very much, Antoine.
ANTOINE BELLO: Merci.
[APPLAUSE]